I'm waiting for her to get shot I'm like
inside I'll labor you your shot today
we're gonna be complementing each other
with a toy lie detector
I'm a gas up queen I will guess anybody
else you do that thing camera you better
record
yeah I think so I'm like why not why
wouldn't we you know if I compliment you
first I mean it because I initiated if
you compliment me I have to scramble to
think of a compliment because that's
just the rules I don't feel that way so
you need to like strap yourself in oh
yeah you can't escape so what happens if
your lie it shocks you alright
you are very smart like when I hired you
and when you went out for that interview
you have so many ideas and things going
on Oh like you do a lot of deep diving
strategizing Wow seasons a lot destiny
your nails are so cute
okay oh my god that's scary I hate this
that's a true kebab I hate this I like
your sense of style that's right a
reasonable citizen wait
I guess I'm telling the truth how do you
like this [ __ ]
I like everything let's see I met you my
intern class and you're the best friend
from my intern class I'm not you're my
real best friend in real life too and I
love you can I talk me yeah I think you
have gorgeous flawless skin I should've
waited I should have worked
I'm leaving I really like your shirt
it's a really nice shirt your life
why do you agree sense of humor thank
you
I'm waiting for her to get shot I'm like
inside I'm late for you yes I I knew it
cuz I rejected my poof and I'm like this
don't feel right that was traumatizing I
like your jeans
it's worse because I know it's not true
I think attractor oh my god it's because
you've been doing it for so long
probably you said like when people
compliment me I like the old compliment
right back like your body and then
things that's shoe really bubbly warm
personality that is a lie cuz I don't
want to get shot
this is so great a compliment okay oh
wow
tbh I like your ankle bracelet I do I
really nice it's a memory there was no
line no except for a couple things right
I will stick to it that I didn't lie I
just talked the hell out of you
[Music]